i've done a lot of videos on the toxic
effect of alcohol on the liver but i
haven't done
a video showing the effects of alcohol
on the
heart tissue so let's talk about that
there is a condition called alcoholic
heart
muscle disease where the heart becomes
very dysfunctional because of the
chronic use of
alcohol but alcohol in general will
create several problems with the heart
tissue
one is it causes an increase of acetyl
aldehyde accumulation now
i've done videos on this on the liver
and this chemical is considered a toxin
or a poison
it's responsible for that the feeling of
a hangover and the body will try to use
certain enzymes to get rid of this
toxin well the same enzymes in the heart
also are trying to get rid of this
toxic poison which is a residue from the
alcohol
also you'll get a decreased protein
synthesis on the myocytes so the heart
cell
is made out of muscle and it needs
protein
to rejuvenate so you're not going to get
a nice turnover of heart cells
dilated chambers so you have different
parts of the heart
okay you have four chambers and these
chambers as they start to enlarge
they don't all enlarge on a symmetry
basis like the right side
might enlarge more than the left and
that creates all sorts of
problems it can also create arrhythmia
problems
and murmurs because now as the heart
is enlarged the valves no longer close
like they're supposed to
also there's going to be increased
inflammation in the heart
which really leads to a lot of problems
with calcium buildup cholesterol buildup
fibrosis of the heart tissue arrhythmias
and then we have another effect of a
decreased ejection fraction
and a decreased contractibility so this
contraction
of the pump which is supposed to push
the blood throughout the body
is impaired we also get a decrease of
anti-apoptosis
pathways now what does that mean there
are certain pathways that are there
to help the survival of the heart muscle
cell called the myocyte
apoptosis is where the cell actually
dies
so we have anti heart muscle cell death
right so
with alcohol you are going to decrease
the effect of this protective mechanism
and you'll have more heart cells that
die
and then we get an increase of calcium
that accumulates inside the cells now
normally we're supposed to have this
ratio
of way more calcium outside the cell
than inside the cell
we do need calcium inside the cell but
that
is very very tightly regulated and
calcium acts as a communication particle
in and out of the cell
one of the problems with alcohol is it
drives too much calcium inside the cell
and you have all sorts of issues
and there's quite a few other things
that will drive calcium inside the cell
too like emf electromagnetic fields
a problem with low potassium because
potassium protects
this calcium overload and what happens
then is you'll start getting arrhythmias
and
palpitations and all sorts of problems
with the pacemaker
of the heart now i know some of you are
going to ask about what about
a little bit of wine each day i heard
that was good for the heart
because of the phytonutrients the
antioxidants the phenols right
well yes that is correct but it's the
exposure to ethanol that's the problem
if you were to consume a half a cup of
wine that may create a little bit of
what's called a hormetic effect which
will
add a little stress to cause the body to
rebound and it you might see positive
changes but
who's going to stop at a half a glass of
wine per night
probably not very many people but i will
say if you're going to drink some wine
occasionally and you want it to create
more recovery there are certain things
that the heart loves
and the biggest thing that it loves is
ketones
fat the heart prefers fat fuel way over
glucose
fuel and that would be the healthy keto
and the intermittent fasting for sure as
a way to recover the damage that alcohol
could create
the other two things that the heart
loves
our omega-3 fatty acids okay
and vitamin e make sure the vitamin e
includes tocatrinos not just
a synthetic tocopherol all right thanks
for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto
absolutely not karen and it's an immune
system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it